au 62e jour de l'offensive russe les
relations entre moscou et l'occident
sont peut-être en train de vivre un
tournant alors que sergueï lavrov a de
nouveau mis en garde hier soir taris que
réelle de troisième guerre mondiale
l'allemagne confirme qu'elle livrera
bien des chars à l'ukraine il s'agit des
fameuses armes lourdes que s'interdisait
jusqu'ici l'occident à fournir à kiev lé
annonce s'inscrit dans une dynamique
celle notamment de ce rendez vous
organisé ce matin par washington sur la
base américaine de ramstein allemagne
une vingtaine de pays ont commencé à
étudier la réponse sécuritaire a adopté
dans l'est de l'europe écoutez à ce
propos tout de suite l'américain lloyd
austin
soyons clairs l'invasion russe est
indéfendable tout comme les atrocités
russe
il s'agit avant tout de nous positionner
d'un point de vue de clarté morale la
russie a choisi de mener une guerre pour
satisfaire les ambitions d'un seul homme
l'ukraine mène une guerre par nécessité
pour défendre sa démocratie sa
souveraineté et ses citoyens
voilà les alliés de l'ukraine qui
envisage des normes désormais à visage
découvert de renforcer leur soutien au
pays alors que le secrétaire général de
l'onu est actuellement reçue à moscou on
va vivre dans quelques instants
d'ailleurs en direct la conférence de
presse antonio guterres est ce aux côtés
de sergueï lavrov gauthier rybinski il
va être intéressant de voir ce qu'il
ressort de les changes à l'heure où
semble-t-il rythme s'accélère oui le
rythme s'accélère vous avez raison d'une
part à cause de eur20 grâce à la
livraison d'armes lourdes c'est à dire
essentiellement des chars des chars
d'assaut
livrée par l'allemagne ce qui est une
révolution totale en allemagne à ma
connaissance depuis 1945 il n'y a plus
d'armes allemande en dehors du
territoire allemand et aussi avec l'a7
comment dirais-je cette animosité et le
terme est faible qu'il y as entre eux
antonio goûteuse et salehi lavrov lavrov
a dit récemment que ou te lâche avait
été particulièrement léger et désinvolte
dans l'application des accords de minsk
qui était censée depuis 2014 régler la
question entre l'ukraine et la russie et
que donc il était très difficile de
parler avec lui vous voyez ça quand un
peu le la rencontre entre entre les deux
maintenant goûter le jeu vient avec un
objectif qui certes très louable qui est
l'objectif humanitaire mais qui n'est
qu'une partie de des données du problème
entre la russie et l'ukraine et entre la
russie et l'occident de plus
généralement donc sans doute que lavrov
pourra donner peut-être des garanties
d'ailleurs que la russie ne tiendra pas
forcément sur le plan humanitaire et
pour le reste on peut douter qu'il y ait
des avancées voilà l'onu qui a appelé
juste avant cette rencontre a doublé le
montant de l'aide humanitaire à qui dit
s'attendre à plus de 8 millions de
réfugiés on en est à 5 millions au
moment où l'on se parle
moscou a mis en garde aussi ce matin et
les japonais vis-à-vis d'exercice naveau
qu'il le mène actuellement aux côtés des
américains il y aussi cette attaque
terroriste dénoncer tout à l'heure par
le conseil de sécurité
convoquée en transnistrie région
séparatiste moldave visé hier par
plusieurs explosions il ya un risque
réel de contagion aujourd'hui gauthier
alors s'il ya risque réel de contagion
soit en clair ce sera du le fait de la
russie on va voir sur cette carte de
quoi il s'agit exactement voilà ce que
ses claques en istrie c'est à dire vous
le dixième de raison c'est un une
portion du territoire moldave la
moldavie est une république indépendante
reconnue par l'onu et puis vous avez ici
vous n'êtes pas loin de odessa là c'est
la frontière ukrainienne et au fond de
quoi il s'agit il s'agit de non pas de
séparatistes comme dans le donbass mais
deux militaires de para militaires de
milice qui réclament depuis à peu près
trente ans leur attachement à la russie
sous des motifs tout aussi fallacieux
que les autres les séparatiste de
transnistrie accuse les moldaves de
mener une politique fasciste boyer qu'on
est dans la même dans le même registre
de de terminologie pourquoi parce que
pour les séparatistes transnistrie la
moldavie n'existe pas simplement c'est
la roumanie qui est derrière et là vous
allez voir qu'on fait encore allusion à
l'histoire l'histoire c'est que pendant
la guerre deuxième guerre mondiale la
roumanie avait un un régime fasciste pro
nazi et que pour les gens de
transnistrie les russes de transnistrie
et bien ça n'a pas changé comme vladimir
poutine qui accuse l'ukraine d'être
toujours nazis vous voyez c'est le même
procédé l'histoire est comme gelée ou
congelés et quand on la ressort bas les
communes it une comédie t il ya soixante
dix ans il ya donc le terreau est
propice i will vient à un dérapage oui
parce que c'est vrai que c'est
exactement la même chose sauf que le
territoire et est plus petit bien sûr
mais le principe est le même et la mort
c'est la même elle consiste à vouloir
défendre des russophones qui sont
d'ailleurs pas toujours pro russe c'est
comme dans le donbass face à un ennemi
qui est présenté comme étant dictatorial
oppressant et oui effectivement
nazifiant d'une certaine manière